happy to be back and I'm delighted to
welcome sue seagulls to our stage I love
you read a little biographical snippet
about her in your program she's a
corporate VP at General Electric and a
particular interest to us the CEO of GE
s healthy imagination behind that
whimsical title is and I'll use g e--'s
words a six billion dollar global
commitment to provide better health for
more people by lowering costs and
increasing access and before that she
was a venture capitalist more David
David L and the president of affymetrix
affymetrix which is a pioneering company
in genomic so obviously if she didn't
exist we would have had to invent her
for this confident but fortunately she
does existence she's here so please
welcome her thank you now so you will
avoid been head of health imagination
since what June fourth month yeah yeah
but before we talk about your vision of
it tell me a little bit about the
organization first you know because as
you found it what it was there for so GE
there's two global initiatives that GE
launched and that was one is eco
imagination and the other one is healthy
imagination ecomagination was launched
in 2005 healthy imagination was launched
in 2010 and the purpose of healthy
imagination as gesammelte saw it was
very much around enabling better health
for more people sounds very simplistic
but when you think about it what do most
folks talk about these days in terms of
some of the big crises education energy
and health care no matter where you go
anywhere in the world that's the
conversation so healthy imagination was
put out there to say well hold on a
second instead of us waiting around for
someone to tell us what to do meaning GE
why don't we figure out what we can do
and put some things into place to start
addressing those three things
and it is very much around quality
access and affordability so just put
into place under best my driver no
gesammelte I'm sorry yeah yeah the
Chairman is CEO of General Electric put
this initiative into place and they
started doing a number of different
experiments pilots if you'd like and
those ranged anything from looking at
access and quality for medical care in
Saudi Arabia as an example where you
would do preventive screening for
example for breast cancer in women now
think about instituting that in Saudi
Arabia all right where you do have the
cultural elements associated to it and
you can't do this alone so we partnered
with the Susan G Komen Foundation and
essentially put into place better access
educated through the surgeon G Komen
Foundation much more that the
technicians and the doctors to be able
to do this and really did increase the
ability to look for early stage cancers
in women we've done that now in
Guangdong China and we've done it in our
own backyard here in Wyoming believe it
or not because when you think about
Wyoming being the state that has won the
lowest screening rates in the country
but also a very rural state how do women
that live in Wyoming actually get access
to preventive screening so those were
some of the pilots that were going on in
addition to that there were just a
number of things like the Cincinnati
project that again gesammelte and the
leadership at GE thought you know the
government or payers or someone is going
to do something to us why don't why wait
around for it to be done to us so GE
will do it to us so GE said why don't we
figure out how to partner with the
community and with our employees and put
things into place that could actually
make a difference and that's what they
set out to do so two years ago before
the does GE GE like actually say we've
got great ideas about health care let's
go to the existing systems here was it
born
of it in patients that nothing was
happening and let's pick it up and do it
ourselves yeah it was born out of a
absolute reality of increasing health
care costs without truly decreasing
increasing the the health of the
consumer base meeting our employees I
mean when you take a look at that GE
spends over a billion dollars a year in
health care for employees and it was
increasing at double-digit rates and
that as you guys know the story of
General Motors right and how much
benefits actually constituted per car
when you start to think about health
care it was the same sort of issues that
were happening in the big major
corporation GES is a payer a large
self-insured employer and that's just
how memories there's over 300,000
employees a G right and you know it's
over 500 sites it's a big company to say
the least so one of the things that had
to happen is let's figure out how to do
this and let's not wait and it was born
out of impatience it was born out of an
initiative it was born out of the desire
to make it better for both the employees
and also for Joe besides like doing
breast screening in Saudi Arabia really
a bulk of the stuff that happens in this
is you know saying let's use this these
three hundred thousand GE employees and
we'll get a grip on our own health costs
which are a big cost for a corporation
and its to figure out what other things
can we do all right and and how do we go
about doing it so you know there is a
program that was instituted called
health ahead with in GE this was a
program that was created with the
leadership of GE and the HR teams many
of you have heard this across
corporations but GE took the GF way and
really put a discipline behind it what
does help ahead what was so healthy
ahead is a separate person who thinks of
slogans and there is a grant you the
great branding organization to say the
least within GE but health ahead is a
program that in essence really allows a
whole bunch of different tools for the
employee base to be able to access
anything from programmatic efforts
around smoking cessation measuring
certain things with regards to your
exercise the ability to have a health
coach for example that you could call to
allow you to figure out if in fact
you're following the right sort of
regimes as it relates to a medical
situation that you might have you name
it ge was offering it out to the
employee base so that employees could be
much more educated if you'd like and get
better access to information they were
not getting the information so this was
one way to help employees make decisions
about health and a lot of you will say
well you know my company kind of offers
some of those programs and can get
engaged and they last for a little bit
GE took it in a very serious way across
the entire leadership of the company
across all the sites and they really put
into place a site certification process
it's very hard I mean you guys gonna
think this is crazy but it's very hard
to find a brownie at GE it's you know
breaks now are really fruits and it is
all about getting healthier because they
fundamentally believe it so it it was a
very systematic way of addressing the
situation with regards to health care
and the testimonials that have come back
for pretty amazing actually only because
I guess you know I'm a corporate
employee and I I have to say and I
imagine a somewhat of a problem in is
tuning systems like this and health is
that I don't necessarily feel that my
even though that I corporation is
involved in the payment of my health I
don't necessarily feel in a sharing mode
when it comes to my health and my
corporation right and you know when they
offer these you know coaching services
like that you know I imagine an impulse
a lot of people would say oh I'm going
to go outside the corporation it's it's
almost like watching people you know
like working out with your your fellow
workers right you know yeah you want to
keep these things separate there how do
you get over that you know there was an
initial what I here and I've only been
there four and a half months so it
I will tell you the stories that I've
heard and there was definitely an
initial sort of will hold on a second
I'm not so sure I want the employers to
get as you know my employer to get so
involved in my health what happened over
time I'm told and I see it now is people
are very engaged with the tool sets that
are offered to them and they've seen the
subsequent results with regards to the
health and the fact that you know health
care social change in behavior is social
it's why weight watchers and alcoholics
anonymous and whatnot has flourished
over the years right and so having in
fact that others were in the same
conversation and really getting
addressed socially if you'd like made an
impact and you know collectively and I
wish we'd collected these stats how much
weight did the entire corporation loss
losing what not and we we probably have
it because we measure everything right
but we haven't publicized that yet and
it is something that I'd love to look
into because it'd be a really
interesting stat a big stack of thought
wouldn't it would she so when when you
think about folks at the beginning
feeling a bit potentially how is this
going to affect how I am that people
don't think about that anymore and
they've seen the benefits versus what
they were have before you got there you
have any any sense that you know was it
one killer app that people adopted or
was it was just now you know one of the
things that I else would go oh no no
there's there one thing I've learned is
it was a mix of apps it was a mix of the
actual physical presence being you know
the diet changing in the cafeterias it
was the ability to actually measure with
the leadership of each of the sites
having to actually account for the
things that they had put into place to
help the employee base so they were
taking it seriously so it's part of the
leadership culture the health coach is
being put into place the active sourcing
that they were doing directly with the
medical suppliers of parts as an example
so
it wasn't just a let's do one thing
which i think you know when we've looked
at other employers some of the challenge
has been there are these pulses that get
offered of these great games as an
example great apps and they get engaged
for three month period and then after
that it's what it goes away how do you
sustain this over time and that is a
very systematic approach that is
actually put into place and it's taken
very very seriously across the
corporation I'll give you an example
there is a health ahead day and it is a
stand-down day and everyone across the
world where then GE really gets involved
in assembly it's very programmatic you
get to participate in all sorts of
different activities that are actually
offered in terms of heights and walks or
competitions really so I don't want to
go I don't go in like my desk that day
and you can't I'd like you can if you'd
like I'll give you another example so
there's tread desks now at a number of
the sites where you can actually you
know book the tread desk for an hour a
day as you're actually on your computer
actually doing it so there is it's not
one thing it is it's the culture of
health right and what about in terms of
shipping costs and making workers you
know have to watch the cost themselves
so this is this is an interesting one so
this is market forces coming to bear
right why is it that we don't know how
much it costs for knee surgery why is it
that you don't know when you go to the
emergency room how much it actually
costs you right and you think about that
situation and that's just something that
has happened over the years after World
War two of course and the incentives for
employers to provide medical care for
their employees that decision alone and
the incentives associated to that has
really caused particularly here in the
United States our addiction to having
somebody else play for our health
so who cares what it costs in a sense
we've we've essentially surrendered it
and said somebody else gets to pay for
it I don't have to worry about it what's
happened now and what employers are
doing across the board is offering all
sorts of different levels of health care
spent high-deductible plans lower
deductible plans and all of a sudden
people are going will hold on a second
I've got to pay for that yeah and guess
what it changes their behavior it
changed my behavior you know you choose
what am I going to go to an urgent care
and get a quick take on this how am I
going to go to the emergency room and
those costs you know the difference is
right and emerging this room can cost
you as high as a thousand dollars a
visit and urgent care will cost you
forty five dollars a visit right and you
probably will get the same sort of
diagnosis if it's not too serious and I
think you're not that sick that you're
going to decide to go if you've got you
know brain hemorrhage you go to the
urgent care center those kind of
decisions the consumerism of health care
the transparency of pricing has to be
put into place for us to actually be
able to really work on this health care
juggernaut so that decision of actually
offering different types of programs was
something that was pretty well thought
out and now all employees in particular
really do look and care about what sort
of medical decisions they're making so
let me as you know you've been in bed
and of course in for a few months and
this is an area expertise for you it was
it a mistake to link healthcare to
employers this is a system we've been
locked into but if you were to start
from scratch would you would you do it
that way no I wouldn't I think that I'm
a big believer in you know individuals
being able to make decisions on things
that affect them and I think it was an
in inverted consequence of putting into
place what needed to be put into place
at the time as it related to being able
to cover health care after the Great
Depression and whatnot making sure that
employers were also safe
as it related to providing the health
care benefits for their employee base
but when you think about it over time
you know really allowing market forces
to come to bear in health care like
they've been in almost any other
industry why shouldn't that happen I
mean that's it's time to do that and so
I think there's a lot of that we're
going to see over the next few years in
terms of you know individuals being able
to make choices as it really relates to
premiums talk to smaller things you're
doing that before that while we're on
sort of a policy attractor what's the
effect of Obamacare going to be on all
your your activities there well you know
call it what you may I think what we
really are focused on more than anything
else is quality access and affordability
and what the whole notion of the ACA put
into place was I think much more
awareness for everybody that it is a
major issue and so I do think that some
of the choices that are being forced
upon them whether they be state or
federal I'm not trying to take a
position here all I'm saying is GE isn't
going to wait for you know whatever it
is that's going to make it easier for
you is to make harder for you you little
food for thought as we go into the
voting booth here for GE are not easier
for GE well I think for the consumer so
I won't speak for GE for the consumer
there will be an initial element of oh
my gosh I have to learn health care how
do I even start and I think if there's
an area for entrepreneurs and startups
to actually think about its how to help
them make these kind of decisions
because it's going to be tough at the
beginning I don't even know how to think
about it as consumer how do I know
what's a better premium or not a better
premium I mean that that is something
that I think is going to be a little
tougher but i do think ultimately over
time the kind of awareness and education
that is being forced upon the US
citizenship from the most sophisticated
to those that really haven't had access
is you know it's a really interesting
time
so I do want to touch on the venture
capital & Co the this a corporate garage
business there's a talk you know which
is right up your wheelhouse as a venture
capitalist they are tell me about what
what you folks are doing in terms of
engaging with third party operations and
even funding startups yep based on Sand
Hill Road right we are so GE one of the
things that it did and one of the
reasons why I came to GE is that the
notion of being able to take the venture
arm which was fairly nascent about two
years old and bringing it in to Silicon
Valley so we're opening up our silicon
valley offices and developing what is an
incubator for some of the disruptive
sort of solutions that are being brought
to the healthcare world and our venture
arm which is called the healthy and
imagination fund is going to be
investing at a number of these types of
you made any investments yes yeah in
fact the fund has actually made some
investments 1 i'll tell you about
they've got about 11 investments at this
point and one that just to give you a
sense of some of the technologies so
imagine a colonoscopy without the
cleansing little too visual for you but
um and we invent really romaji without
the clones without the cleanser and and
this is one of the technologies we
invested in which is an Israeli company
called cap check which essentially is an
imaging device a pill that you swallow
and it takes 3d pictures as it goes
through your peristaltic you know your
intestines and takes pictures and would
that be nice you can go golf and have a
colonoscopy at the same time I mean it's
just very cool so it's it's really
bringing new technologies to bear that
frankly we wouldn't have looked at in
the core businesses that's out there for
a little bit and we're going to look at
health care services to which are
disruptive like we just heard about the
telemedicine world which is you know
fantastic it has to go there I think we
all know that convenience is going to be
something really important to all of us
so we're looking at all of it and the
notion of the corporate garage is also
around what we're calling the scalar
ater and this is someone's invention
within GE and that is bringing GE
scale to help startups get to scale
faster so one of the things will help do
is you know how do you how do you figure
out GE how do you even find the right
people within GE to actually make this
happen we're going to be your Sherpas in
essence within GE to find you the right
expertise and hopefully be able to help
some of these startups actually get to
scale a little bit faster ok so we don't
time for questions the audience there is
one comment on twitter i will bring out
cuz you mentioned the you know uh the
food you have it je so you don't have
junk food anymore or desserts things
like that you know someone from twitter
basically said well you know it doesn't
think very much that removing brownies
doesn't foster willpower self-control
actually have you found that people are
healthier by just forcing you know Kalon
them during the day uh you know I I have
to say people will tell you in fact they
will actually provide testimonials even
on the website they'll do this that they
have found themselves to be healthier so
so far so good I mean we know that
Neutron you're not monitoring them you
don't have one of those scanners we are
not in monitoring Tim big brother is not
there no no that's good well I'm
comforting to know so thanks very much
thank you